to make a decision to run as an
independent I mean history kind of
proves
itself can't you how you can't win you
can't win well I know that you're you're
now trying to make it so that your name
is on the ballot in every state right
that's like what your goal is now
because in the past it's been very
difficult for someone who's running as
an independent to even make it that far
yeah I mean I'm in better shape than any
independent in 100 years but than any
independent have we ever elected an
independent well George Washington was
elected as independent so we have a
great track record count yeah of course
not but you know we're not we're at a
different time in history right now and
and my numbers are better than any
independent who's ever run right but
isn't it if you if you legitimately
you're a smart person if you
legitimately want to win do you
legitimately want to win or are you
looking to damage one of the sides no of
course not I'm I'm I'm running to win
and if I had to put money on it I would
put money on
myself how how is that just knowing just
knowing
the listen you're you're you're you've
been involved your family has been
involved in politics your entire life
and there you're uh you know royalty as
far as uh you know politics goes you
understand media and that and and and it
just doesn't we don't do that we I was
born in Canada but but uh America
America just doesn't do that they're
very tribal there there there's new
things being done every day and let me
just I tell you this that I'm already
winning I'm beating both president TR
Biden and president Trump in people
under 45 years old I'm beating them and
I'm beating them by a landslide in
people under
35 I'm beating them in the largest
cohort which is the independence people
are unaffiliated I win that cohort I am
why is that the largest cohort because I
think there are for the for the first
time in history the first election in
history Independence out uh
out out are are larger are more
numerous than either Democrats or
Republicans this is the first time in
history in registered voting yeah
registered voting there are more reg
registered independ people who are who
declare themselves are self- declared
independence but register they call them
now in the polls unaffiliated voters but
who say I'm not a Democrat and I'm not a
republican they are now the voter
largest voting block and I am I beat
Trump and Biden among Independence I
beat Trump and Biden among people under
35 I'm in a three-way tied with Hispanic
voters I beat them decisively in
Landslide among women who have children
under 18 years of age the only cohort
where I don't do very very well is uh
baby boomers now that's the cohort that
you would expect would support me the
most because they're the ones that
remember Camelot that's
keny but they don't like me because they
want they get their news from TV and
people people who get their news from TV
are going to have a very low opinion of
me and because the television networks
are you know uniformly against me they
get their but not only TV you know your
um your perceived stances on things have
been very very controversial and even
off off of TV on social media as you
just opened up this discussion with you
were you were
banned
he